this is weird mageddon part 3 the final
episode of gravity falls is Robin
sweater town I'm in sweater town can you
not accept the end it is fiver to come
no it's not
two whole seasons somehow in four years
uh that's a shame definitely a shame
come out maybe what if I gave you you
would don't patronize me with a pig my
waddles um by a fan made both of those
it's amazing I apologize I forget
because I think at one point we actually
had two waffles Tamra's got the other
one yes but I only get waiting I only
gave it to her if she promised to watch
the damn show and I'm gonna fuckin hold
it what else she has no excuse it's all
gonna be available and you can see it
all I mean it's in Heights I kind of a
short seer well it's two seasons I don't
know if I say it's a short series or
there's a lot of episodes in there I'm
kind of shocked they didn't just do
three um but I don't know the background
or producers anything like that well
they got their hiatus after hiatus but
it's always okay because they always
gave such good quality shows and they
were always so creative um yeah whatever
I'm just waiting to do this one last
time
ah hardly at the end all right you know
I say the end I can't deal with this
okay I just can't
now what the fuck are we gonna watch on
they'll recommend shows don't recommend
show they don't like moving out of walls
it work away from well what's a Steven
universe - until everybody knows of them
bottles bay the dough crossover like
Uncle grandpa
oh-wee well they'll be like where they
got yeah they would but it would be
something messed up word be like grunkle
Stan and uncle grandpa and Stephen
unisys know um so okay I think most if
you're watching this you've seen the
episode I don't think we have to give a
description of what happened or anything
um it's a pretty good ending it's just
as big it's just this epic I want to see
someone a convention cosplay as the
mystery shack geared up with the
dinosaur you know sometime buddy is
worth I gotta get on that somebody is
doing like if I cosplayed I would I
don't care what I'd have to go through I
would make that but I don't love love
soos bringing anime into it if anime has
taught me anything what we need is a gun
sword
what's anime I have much to teach you um
and I like that they try to throw kinda
like what they've done with the past
couple episodes and this big finale said
they try to control as much gravity
falls into this gravity falls finale as
they can
everywhere you look there's a creature
there's a gnome there's the little golf
balls from the putt-putt place and you
know there's the giant bear and they
tried to get the celebrity's bag who did
the voices you know Harry King who let's
just be the easiest guy in the world to
get into a giant robot how fascinating
I'm free I feel like he just ad-libbed
that like he was watching like you know
some early footage of the show and they
just recorded him saying he was like
that some Larry King would say cuz Larry
King said it um and they go after bill
cipher uh and stays Stan and his brother
had to finally come to grips and they
have to make up again kind of that I
very obvious Disney you know message
that's always like the one nitpick I
have on the show is that I always knew
what the messages are gonna be but again
for Disney let any of this out
especially in this episode because I
felt like there was a lot of stuff that
you know Disney was like we would
usually wave the finger and say no on
this but because it's gonna be fun to
try a lot of money
first time ever I feel bill cipher
legitimately threatening like I've
always kind of been like haha he's kind
of funny like but when he turned into
that weird spider version of himself and
he's like I'm gonna kill one of them at
random I was like oh shit
see I got real I always say even though
he's a funny character I always felt he
was legitimately threat I couldn't I
could not you know she has drawn so
silly and he has such a silly voice and
there is something about there giving
Sauron I and the doctor claw boys and
like eight arms and all of a sudden I'm
like okay now I'm kind of scared of this
you know what it's like remember like in
daredevil the kingpin we just randomly
kills that guy and it causes always
probably you just know he can do this at
a say it's the same thing it's like
there's that immaturity but he's so
dangerous that that combination is just
kind of a scary way I like how his whole
thing about being trapped in two
dimensions was killing him and yet
technically we're watching an animated
show so he's still trapped in two
dimensions well not not here there's two
to interesting things one I was shocked
they didn't have him CG I would have
thought that what been the obvious route
but at the very end when they cut to the
camera that looked live-action so maybe
they're hinting at something with that -
they made there's an R 3 dimension I try
looking over to put on my skeptical I
know maybe maybe not I me said the
creator's going on to all their stuff I
mean he doesn't have any plans to do
anything else that we know of with
gravity falls um and he's moving unto
Fox seems like a demotion to me yes
usually it's the other way around but he
did so well with Disney and Disney as
the friggin Saints with this show I mean
if I still get away with well with this
Fox it think up Bob's Burgers I like
that that's on Fox right yeah um but I
even watched exceptions I mean that's
Family Guy yeah that's still on very
fresh very very new material um yeah so
you know what but that's good maybe goes
like - maybe he'll fix Fox yeah you know
maybe he'll bring something to it um but
yeah this uh so that this is a great big
grand epic fight like every
character you can imagine gets in there
they even just like the tiniest things
when they make this mystery shack into
sort of like this anime Power Ranger
concoction it's all stuff I also like on
the way in true anime form the things
powered by fucking angst yeah it's
always it's like Evangelion it's a bunch
of kids inside going wrong those are
Evangelion it would have been dipper
sitting there for 26 episodes deciding
whether or not to get in the shack robot
so so um I'm just gonna go into order
here the we both caught on very quick
and Stan we're gonna switch clothes I
think it's over the age of 138 get there
for now yeah um but but it's still fine
as welcome it's a good arc and
everything I like that I like the way
that their relationship plays out
similar to the way dippers and Mabel's
it that they're kind of mirror images of
each other yeah only as ace it's like
well how did dipper Mabel do easy their
kids didn't know any better
um and I like I like the the way they
showed cipher disappearing but also him
kind of disappearing the blue fire I I'm
not gonna lie a part of me really wanted
his memory to be gone like and if it was
gonna come back you would die very
slowly spread it back you see that's and
I know that's Disney or just the
sentimental side or whatever but you
know this would have been really
effective if his memory stayed why he
would and maybe just a little bit was
remembered like giving a chance maybe
I'll come back rules waddles
okay the fucking balls Jesus Christ um I
have you know big um I actually agree
with you right I got your just I thought
heartbreaking I thought at first they
were gonna do that but the more they're
going on I'm like no they're gonna find
some way out of this I'm like you can't
do this out of kitchen I will say this
Kristen Schaal deserves an Emmy for
their performance because when she
started breaking down
Oh grunkle Stan like I was like oh my
god I'm like this is horrible I think
she
has enough a warrant she's like but
every was she like sneezes and she got
one egg that was like the / 4 that was
the performance of the show was here
just sick uncle Stan I was like Oh God
um and I feels yeah I liked that he
couldn't remember I thought me what I
thought maybe they were gonna do is like
he remembers waddles and they're like it
and maybe there's hope and like you
start see like maybe over ty actually he
slowly gets it okay so I actually
thought it was gonna end pretty much
right there when they were going through
the scrapbook and then it fucked all the
Return of the King on it oh it felt like
five Return of the King ladies man this
cow so much it's fucking debt yeah so
you have for dehydration they're going
on this great big climax this nice area
where I'm cat with you it could have
ended again like return the kid they
make it look like it's gonna there but
that's like no no that that was that big
one we have five more of these give Evan
like give us this no it's not fake us at
there was one fake out I think when
they're reading the scrapbook I thought
okay you can end in here and then they
kept going I'm like okay after that it
wasn't faking us out and the funny thing
is actually don't mind the ending to
return the king I just hated the fade
outs because the fade outs kept making a
big cartoon a fucking like okay here we
go and it's I know that's what bothered
mean this did not make that mistake it
tricked you once into thinking made was
gonna end and when it kept going you
just knew it was gonna keep going and
then finally one of them did you're like
okay and this is where it ends like you
can see it well not like you keep
wanting to get up to you know go do
something else or something I think the
end credits are gonna roll so I mean if
I was if I was like in charge of a this
at directing a wouldn't be nearly as
good as it is so I'm not at all making
any arguments a bad idea if I was an
editor I would pick maybe Allah which is
there's about five endings I would pick
maybe I pick probably two maybe three
was getting a little AI ish but Mabel
and dipper never had a birthday party so
you know the ones where I really want to
edit get it it's waddles it's when one
old sign
don't know how to tell you this and I'm
kind of thinking like oh come on
Oh dare you
it's world okay here's with all of it
all of it I mean the stuff L was like
actually legitimately sentimental and
then the stuff that like you know okay
that fellow forth all of it I felt was
100% earned and they have the right to
do all of that and we can and yes it
where it has something in common with
return the king because as much as I
consider me like I am eternal King me
and they it goes on forever I'm like
they fucking are dead yeah like I really
can't complain they earned every you
know I glazing moment of it like if they
wanted to show you know Frodo putting
together a dictionary of middle-earth
terms they probably earned that too and
then Sam sits there and plant some more
fuckin petunias and then merry and
pippin ders smoking on the fence and
fall over and die like they were off of
it anyway but no they just kept their PI
surges overdose sorry I'm just like Oh
II I'm really on that visual oh I get
out of it gravity pas gravity falls
point being that they would have heard
all that and think this show totally
earns every fucking minute I don't care
how boring they could have made it it
would have just still earned it the
stuff that really stood out to me is
like nice ease and really the stuff with
Wendy I thought was very nicely done I
loved the switching of the hats you know
cuz that's like the only kinda super
hand I love she takes it off and gives
her you're gonna have giving yet cuz ya
know I was so looking for a hand like
what Wendy had cuz I wanted to have that
I'll get some put that on when I could
run around like Eddie from National
Lampoon's Christmas vacation I can't
swim car sure was full yeah there honey
dipper says sugar school that's what she
says oh come on dipper
merciful oh by the way if you have kids
don't watch IV logs for adults its
adults watching a children's show but it
doesn't feel like your children show uh
no does it makes you feel like an mo but
most of it worry there are some bits
where I'm just like this is deciding
whether or not to give sousta I'm like
II just handed it to you could've done
that in the picture in the scrapbook
yeah yeah yeah you know waddles you
didn't have to have the well I can't by
now you're gonna dance up yo you did
your shoe didn't occur some days
pologize it tastes like very well
knitted bacon it tastes like you aren't
a bacon um but uh yeah I would even say
you know probably like the little
birthday party you didn't probably need
any I feel like no no you needed that I
mean I are gonna keynote if you're go if
you're gonna keep it going
and they decided obviously that they are
you needed the 13 birds because that's
what think we're talking about 13
everything changes yeah no that's true
oh that's true they do you still get
waddles with me um ooh where's the
Secession waddles and me ah Wheatley
defiled the sport page now Idaho Kermit
the Frog feels um but it's a very uh I
feel like you know on the bus and look
at the little letter and the little
monologue that dipper has you know if
you ever passed by a places to again I'm
thinking like you know how does one like
of a past life and stuff but it you know
they sought return the king said fuck it
they were on tour but and we want that
too we want everyone to have their
curtain call that's always how I saw
Return of the King if everybody gets
different asked me what the best moments
were in the ending it is that initial
part with Mabel good girl instead haha
and him rediscovering his memories and
then literally you could have fast
forwarded to the bus ride yeah that's um
those are the two Stan emotes
everything in between lots of delicious
icing on the cake but it's a it's a
whole bunch of icing and may
you could have just used a chocolate
ganache I don't but it's a whole bunch
of whipped cream where you probably just
gone with a little whipped cream and a
cherry on top but you know what was a
fucking love whipped cream
all right well I think they know the
connection that everybody has with the
show that so many adults have with the
show this is the ending that a lot of
fan fiction writers would probably write
and stuff and they're like let's let's
give it to them let's just you know
totally let's make it fan fiction proof
even nobody can expand on this well yes
they can just sexually but we're that
gun ah there we go okay where's that she
destroy the memory gun now I have to
remember twincest uh and I like I like
that that's how they get rid of bill
cipher - I like that it's the gun I like
that's the sacrament like that all tie
lighting really nice all tied together
incredibly well on stand deciding to
sacrifice himself yeah um I love the way
that everybody came together to pitch in
and help and that it was kind of divided
evenly between cuz a lot of this has
been like well you know Mabel's like the
emotional core but dippers kind of the
brains if I only wanted in too much I
feel like I feel like a lot of you know
the show is based kind of around dipper
oh he's as far as this an that but
really was dipper and Mabel working
together the second Mabel whipped out
that grappling hook
I literally shut it fuck I just couldn't
wait and like the way they fought
together and we're outwitting bill
cipher I loved it
like it was teamwork oh yeah I'm trying
who did try the Pacifica did it I mean
she holds the hobos hand I guess and
that's like a big thing um
I am kind of said they never did
anything with her and now they wait to
see some come with me you could tell
that at some point they've just like we
don't have time it was you know what it
was the Egon um Jeanine romantic
investors one yeah it's just like and
we're gonna have this kind of
awkwardness I mean we're going somewhere
I got a wreck around him yeah we're good
but whatever we we didn't have time ran
out of time
um yeah and it's like again Oh real
nipping any problem I have of this is
uber nitpick um kind of like all the
episodes and do we ever see like a bad
pisode of gravity falls out now dead and
I feel like I would remember I'm gonna
have Steven universe hands kill me for
this but I have seen bad episodes of
Steven you first yeah not many very few
but involves Ronaldo can go ahead yeah I
there's not an episode of gravity falls
I'm just like well that was a bad
episode that can go to hell
there's some lesser ones where I'm just
like that was fun but you know yeah um
yeah I just what can I say the summer's
over
Georgia City goodbye was definitely over
here anyways imagine and then they get
home after all this like well back to
school well and I like the I like that
the last picture you see is them just
arriving home and they're both asleep
and so little touches like that really
like I like the scrapbook in the credits
and everything oh no the that last image
of them falling asleep on the bus was
just so quick ya know I really like that
um so yeah trying to think anything else
and it turns up like is this like my new
favorite show or anything I've ever
stars still in my favorite show oh well
that's kind of apples into orange no no
just in general I mean lays it I I say
might be in like my new top 10 look at
least I did my new favorite show well
it's either Jessica Jones or gravity
falls uh liquid
no no just in general like a show they
can watch over to Bremen they have
nothing in common I can't you oh no no
no I wasn't comparing avatars I have any
verbs if I'm saying that just in a
general topic today Tarot no general top
ten I I hit the pig I smacked the pig I
sound like a porno name and I did it so
there's a lot of stuff oh he's like
really who she does that
that's animals baby I'm gonna let you
near this thing you need to get that
thing Ruby's really should somebody Pig
shed it happens listen all right pixie
pigs do have hair a little bit I don't
know what your shed
yeah but I probably my top ten they
wallow in mud actually to cool off yeah
like everybody knows that babe you saw
the same National Geographic special no
like me just pick it up Oh what when
you're wallowing with the pigs yes
you've never been we're getting off
topic okay
uh anything else I think this was one of
those shows that's like you can kind of
show it to anyone it's timeless for the
most part a few jokes I'll be there's
like some of the phrases but there's a
number of jokes I think it's definitely
aimed for adults as well and has 80s
awareness which I like like it's aimed
at put so much stuff now has of 80s and
90s vibe to it yeah do you know even
kids instead of the physics lab it's not
adults it's not aimed at adults as well
is something like a major Disney film
like frozen where it's like okay well an
adult who's 60 could watch it it's
definitely aimed more towards our idea
um you know 20s 30s you know but again
your knees maybe don't get into some of
those jokes like the initial humor of
the characters is strong and the mystery
is strong all the stuff is is revealed I
mean it doesn't pull a loss like we
pretty much get all the answers I wish
lost ended like this that would have
been a great ascending ever just have
the Iowa girl like hands and legs and
star punch a smoke monster it's looking
better what we fucking got yeah uh so
yeah this is uh I just think this is
such a nice for session for a show it's
only two seasons to all I can think
about done is Benjamin Linus saying
they're good you know is this mean what
I think it means you mean a house that
stands and walk some legs yes John what
time-traveling bunny which I'm traveling
bunnies and know what time-traveling
babies yes yes I still feel bad for time
David is like he never comes back
bit of a dick he never came just a baby
just I don't think he was a baby I think
that's the form he took Rob forget about
the baby
mash back back did it from my bed back
um so yeah I'm just really glad I
discovered this show I'm glad that the
fan that got me uh that DVD got me that
DVD because I don't know when I woke
again
to watch it I think I was just sick one
day and it just the DVD looked really
good it was just a good cover here so I
finally put it on I was just hooked I
mean just addicted and I'm glad I got
you addicted to it also and I was like
dude you gotta watch it just got to
watch it you did making me watch the
loser candy episode and going you'll
never figure out what they're spoofing
here spirited away oh you know that you
know that reminds me of something else
in this last episode that actually did
legitimately like really tug a heart
string where you just kind of look
around the shack and the stuff that's
left over there's just a little bit of
paper that just says who is your author
is that really tight like that
legitimate took me back like I remember
when that verse happened the water'll
school and the this glitter and the
sparkles in the way that room was just
empty I was just like oh but but that
lie in particular because it really
charm fields because it really jars and
memory because that's one of the first
major questions just who is the author
and you know you wanna find out you want
discovery just it just immediately
reminds you of what a huge journey this
was and even though it's it's a comedy
and it makes a lot of fourth-wall jokes
and it's a kid show and stuff like that
and you just feel you've been on this
amazing journey it's quite the adventure
I would show it to like anybody I know
as kids I'd be like you need to watch a
show yeah any of Thomas I would be yeah
a guy watching yeah Tara doesn't have
any kids and we're all we're both like
you gotta watch that show like this is
just good you know she did better watch
it she didn't play a pregnant woman in a
play recently so I that Wow
okay alright unless that was just a
Rouge a Rouge a like a Moulin Rouge
what a Rouge pairing don't try to speak
French okay ever
you're like grunkle Stan speaking French
um but uh yeah any any last words I just
I'm just really sad it's not right
models comfort me um I feel like it left
at the right time no I this is a good
time to stop there's a couple things and
the whole Pacifica thing I'm kind of
like
yeah I get the feeling that they had
another season they probably want to
flush that out more but I yeah I go out
on top
I would always well I mean look at
Simpsons and Family Guy it's just like
that's what happens when you just let
something go and you just see this this
poor dying corpse wedding I would never
want to see that happen to this show so
um they went out on top and one
adventures Ben and summer's over now we
got to go back to school oh one last
thing
final swatch it was a birthday cake and
then the the shooting star like it said
on the giant simple circle thing that
actually played no part what do you
think about it didn't do anything why
it's because they couldn't hold out by
love that you seen this at the beginning
of each episode at the end of each
episode and it does nothing it doesn't
play a role like that's actually really
funny oh you know they said the prophecy
in seven they're right they all came
together at a help but it wasn't in that
way like that I will know there are
other sweaters first watch alert we had
soos in the pink tiger II thing and
Pacifica had a llama I don't know why
well no no okay I do like that as soon
as like he draws the circle Rob just
goes the sweaters it's all gonna be the
sweaters and I'm like partially right
there are a couple sweaters like a
hoodie a destiny the hoodie a fucking
desk I was like dude there's Stan's hat
there's obviously dippers symbol there's
you know the okay so they weren't all
sweaters but like I just it's rented
from you guys for years like I didn't
fuckin buy there for that well no I knew
that I knew dippers had and I knew
maples but I know what the fucking llama
was about and Pacifica was wearing a
llama sweater and Rabia the hoodie of
destiny that's why I said the sweaters
and yo he said to ruin my moment didn't
you hide it now I can't even remember
with the other sweaters were thanks a
lot hat so how was it now they were oh
turn all in terms of the rest the
episode yet on the codes were kind of
just like you know semi you know ooh
will there be more the answer is no and
then goodbye and hello and say you know
beginning is the end the end of the
beginning like that kind of stuff
summer's over that's what I can yeah but
there will always be memories yes so
yeah I don't want to feel anything I
want to punch my heart I can't feel
anything
punch mine too I better get out of the
sweater do a season for me you can do